I will say this I wasn't a fan of lizzo
when she was disrespecting our [__]
country playing that Thomas Jefferson's
flute that pissed you off that angered
me I was so mad I was on Twitter under
all my all accounts yes I was I was I
was saying all kinds of mean things and
cats once I found out how she treats
dancers behind the scenes I actually
really like lizard
[Music]
this is all this is for all the dancers
are in the room Hey listen up listen up
the zoo all right me and Joe you got
fans of uh you guys fans of lizzo I'm a
fan of her now yeah I'm a big fan after
this dude I'm a huge fan of her irony
former lizzo dancers were apparently
weight shamed and pressured while at a
strip club and now she is under a
lawsuit her and apparently the dance
Captain why was she like you're not fat
enough to be a part of my crew no no the
other way around really yeah they
followed the three former dancers filed
the suit against the accusing the singer
of sexual harassment and creating a
hostile work environment I think she's
innocent dude free [__] lizzo because
isn't she the one that's always saying
that other people are weight shaming her
all the time definitely yeah definitely
you gotta take it out on somebody but if
you're if you're like secretly gay don't
you call people gay that's true I do
damn that's official secretly fast what
kind of fast shaming was she doing on
her crew was her crew like like
like they're like 250 pounds and then
she's like I need you to be like 200
like 40. I honestly think that is what
happened yeah sort of like you're trying
to sound like you're too fat I think
because isn't her whole crew fat yeah
they are but they're all the dancers are
but then I think like they got more
weight on them and she would maybe so
she's like the limit is 300 pounds
you're [__] 320. it's honestly just
like a speeding ticket you know it's
like hey this would be level 65 around
here people get written up at work all
the time you know so she was weight
shaming like they weren't heavy enough
or they were they were going too heavy
they're getting too heavy I think that
she's like hey look I'm the biggest girl
on stage like you you wanna outshine me
you go do some you could do that I'll
make sure you never work in this town
again let's have a [__] carrot stick
once a month it is it is a really dicey
situation though because when you when
you see like a lot of professional
dancers have chimed in on the whole
[__] thing and they're like it's kind
of normal that like if you book a job
and let's say you weigh 145 and you your
costumes that are made for you are
Taylor to your shape you kind of can't
change shape because then they have to
kind of do work and do it all over like
yeah like you you maybe can't [__]
cut your hair or maybe if your hair is
too crazy you have to dye it back to a
certain color so you don't stand out
more than the artist like there's a
bunch of stuff even in Apparel Design
it's like that too right it is like of a
fit model and then you create to that
fit model and that person's not allowed
to gain or lose weight dude Christian
bill got too fat for the back
of the back you had to slim down yeah
they made the bet they call him a fatty
the whole set it is that's why it's
dicey here because like because these
these dancers are supposed to be
professional in that way but I don't
think
um I think I'm not sure if they are I
think they're just kind of more like
newer so it's weird if you're hiring
people to be like I guess like fat
inclusive then you kind of can't make
them follow the same parameters at
product I mean you guys being dancers
how often do you come around a fat
dancer like is it common yeah they're
out there for sure they're out there but
it's not necessarily like it's it's more
so that it's like lizzo's kind of Mo and
her public stance on like all inclusive
and like fat shaming and all that stuff
you know the idea of it seems
contradictory it is contradictory to
what she's about but like all the time
like even we were just talking about the
suit I've been cutting weight because
I've been doing dances lately you know
what I mean to make sure that I'm like a
certain type of look it's not
necessarily a man that's right hell yeah
it's not necessarily mandatory but it it
will stand out if you don't like you
know keep yourself in shape in a certain
way and that's kind of part of the thing
um we've
we've been I I was just part of that
tour in China where one of our guys
compared to last time has been out of
shape and he's put on like 10 15 pounds
so it wasn't like dude you're getting
fat but it's kind of like you're fine
hey um make sure you keep up with your
conditioning you know what I'm saying so
that we can we can get the show in China
you kept your stuff to dance around you
can't just be straight up like hey
you're too fat for the roll I'm nice oh
I see is it nice to talk around it and
not just say what it is like Hey we're
sending you to jail and not like sending
you to the Department of Corrections I
think it's more that like you're
protected under the fact that it's
there's job parameters so it won't be a
discriminatory comment to say like hey
we all have to be at this weight for
this job yeah but I think when you enter
this world of like oh let's be so
inclusive then now how do you say hey
there's a thousand pound weight limit
for this stage we can't all be on this
side like how do you make these like
comments yeah that's true you know like
they're not gonna build the stage to
support because one's feelings based the
other one's like actual numbers based
yeah I think it complicates it can I
show you something real quick see this
weight limit on the stage
even though it says four people that's
four people that weigh 150 pounds we're
talking about a cataclysmic event yeah
that's that's what I think is that's
what I think is odd well so so there's
there's multiple like elements it's not
just the way what's another thing about
a banana yeah there's a banana feature
there is there is here's the thing
though okay I'm not choosing any stances
I'm gonna choose just choose a step I
think I already know what stance on them
well has anybody been to Amsterdam and
seen a live sex show no oh yes I have
I've been to the livestock show yeah
that was a part of it really how so
no there was a girl at the window and
then she said you want to be on the show
and I was like sure and I walked in and
she goes okay 100 euros to see it and
I'm like okay I gave it to her and then
we had sex
I don't think that's the live sexual
weird it's not I think that's just the
regular red light district uh work I
think you paid a hooker to have sex with
you yeah I thought I was doing a live sh
it was live
with someone that you weren't aware of
well I don't know was she on her phone
was she doing her taxes what she had
TurboTax I saw a live sexual yeah it's
like a theater and then the curtains
opened up and as soon as the curtains
opened up it was a rotating Circle
mattress with a dude boning a chick
already totally yeah so I've seen this
suit and but there's it's almost like a
variety show right there's like moments
where like girl puts ping pongs in her
vagina shoots them out there's a moment
where she calls out like a fat dude on
stage like from the audience she puts a
Sharpie interview yeah girl smoking a
cigarette with a [__] yeah so there's
like a bunch of random and then a banana
thing also happens there's a mountain
where there's she puts a banana and
opens it and then somebody has to eat oh
yeah yeah I remember that out of her
vagina yeah yeah
that bad dude it's got a potassium show
so that's that's the only thing it's I
think because I unders I've seen a show
like this too that uh when I heard this
or when I read the story and again I
don't know if that's the exact situation
but they're saying at a club in
Amsterdam they went to something like
this and then you know you know what I
mean and it's like the context if you
don't know that these shows exist it's
like that is sexual harassment when I
heard about that but if you do hear the
of this cultural context she just took
them to a sex show that's what I'm
saying but they were pressured to they
felt pressure to participate because the
power Dynamic of like they I'm so sick
of that [__] excuse me yeah that's
[__] [__] everyone's
talking like an adult you can't let this
guy tell me hey Bart asked me to eat a
banana out of a vagina I'm gonna do it
because he's way bigger than me
he's like I'm sick of this but I'm gonna
do it okay look Nick's in a room where
he's got peer pressure to get a tattoo
and he's actually gonna go through it
I'm gonna do it yeah officially on
camera you don't have to do it
but you do no I want to do it so bad
power Dynamic [__] is [__] so that
was there so that was their sexual
harassment thing is like we went to a
sex show and Amsterdam I had to eat
[__] banana [__] that's what they're
saying did you see the [__] the flip
side of this [__] with the dancers
so like it came out like when everyone
is looking into it is now finding out
that those dancers are scam artists or
at least one of them is like a heavy
religious like
kind of like a uh what is it called like
a religious fanatic and has been pushing
like Christian values like on the whole
like Camp yeah that's a Vibe killer too
a little bit
and that person got we can't just hang
out with the power Dynamic to go to a
sex show so that's why there's like a
that's why there's a problem with all
these things is because it's like
against her religious values can't you
be religious and eat bananas out of
[__] though yeah dude I mean pussy's
natural maybe in church yeah and so is
banana that's what I'm saying for lizzo
if she's not with your values that's the
other thing that's what that she got
hella problems too that's that's another
stance but then also you know maybe
that's just her way of infiltrating and
affecting the people that need it I
don't know I think people are just
[__] weird I think people are funny
but you're gonna start seeing that
coming out because they're they're
trying to like Leverage The Other Side
by exposing that part by being like Oh
the only reason they're having this
issue is because like they were already
hard to work with because of their
values they were trying to and I guess
they've already been told that they were
being a problem because of the religious
[__] isn't this how dancers should be
treated sometimes too yeah I think so
that's what I'm saying please explain I
wasn't a fan I will say this I wasn't a
fan of lizzo when she was disrespecting
our [__] country playing that Thomas
Jefferson's flute that pissed you off
that pissed me off that angered me I was
so mad I was on Twitter under all my all
accounts yes I was I was I was saying
all kinds of mean things in cash once I
found out how she treats dancers behind
the scenes I actually really like Liza
didn't you go to a lizzles show so yeah
I was never really a fan I didn't I was
never really a fan of lizzo but
um uh Nina's one of her best friend's
boyfriend does uh Liz was makeup so like
they ended up getting us tickets yeah I
know when we were in Vegas
yeah we bounced we bounced from your
house yeah my house my party yeah you
left my party yeah it was worth it to go
see lizzo lizzo and then honestly I was
like she's [__] dope I was like this
is a sick show she's super dope did you
ever feel scared up for the stage at any
point yeah was there a lot of stopping
from from Fat peoples this is I'm in
this industry I'm not gonna say these
words I'll say it off camera do you
think okay let me if you do if the stage
had a face do you think that face would
be like
oh please like Thomas the Tank Engine
you fat shamer oh geez just because
you've been losing weight and looking
good it is true though it's like lizzo's
[__] is [__] dope but I also I also
don't care like it's not doesn't do
anything for me that she's fat I don't
really care the same way I don't care if
Etta James has abs yeah it's like who
gives a [__] because music is like why
she's a great performer she's fun to
watch I will say Elizabeth did come out
with a public statement yesterday on IG
yeah and she said um
uh these last few days have been gut
wretchingly difficult and overwhelmingly
disappointing my work ethic morals and
respectfulness have been questioned my
character has been criticized usually I
choose not to respond to false
allegations but these are as
unbelievable as they sound and too
outrageous to not be addressed these
sensationalized stories are coming from
former employees who have already
publicly admitted that they were told
their behavior on tour was inappropriate
and unprofessional as an artist I've
always been very passionate about what I
do I take my music and my performances
seriously because at the end of the day
I only want to put out the best art that
represents me and my fans with passion
comes hard work and high standards
sometimes I have to make hard decisions
but it's never my intention to make
anyone feel uncomfortable or like they
aren't valued as an important part of
the team I'm not here to be looked at as
a victim but I also know that I'm not
the villain that people in the media
portray me to be these last few days I'm
very open with my sexuality and
expressing myself but I cannot accept or
allow people to use that openness to
make me out to be something I'm not
there's nothing I take more seriously
than the respect we deserve as women in
the world I know what it feels like to
be body shamed on a daily basis and
would absolutely never criticize or
terminate an employee because of their
weight I'm hurt but I will not let the
good work I've done in the world be
overshadowed by this I want to thank
everyone who has reached out and support
to lift me up during this difficult time
what do you think at the end of the day
all she did was feed dancers fruit God
for [__] bid yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
honestly I think that's a pretty good
apology I think the the freaking funny
things is the three problems to me are
this one is like now it's like from the
dancer point of view
it's like it's the whole inclusiveness
mixing with the what was previously
professionalism because that doesn't fly
nowadays and plus the second thing is
vet your [__] Camp don't hire people
that are going to have a religious
conflict of what you're doing yeah
that's it if you think someone's going
to complain about eating a banana out of
a vagina that's something you should
have seen as a tour manager or as her
manager should go like oh we can't have
these people on tour because it's a
potential lawsuit in the future I like
the idea that Liz was sitting there and
she's like sometimes I have to make
tough decisions and she's like should I
make the dancers eat bananas out of
[__] or no
or cherries at the butt yeah because
like that but also the dancer if you're
a Christian right what the [__] are you
doing going into a sex show in the first
place that's what I'm saying I gotta
sleep early I'm tired yeah just remove
yourself from the situation all this
could be easily avoided but that's why I
believe it because that's the thing that
happens all the [__] I can say that
will happen yeah you go out with your
entourage as an artist you're everyone's
gonna do [__] that maybe not that wasn't
everyone's idea but but if you went out
that's kind of like you shouldn't have
just gone out yeah it's on you we've all
been on tour I'm the one that [__]
leaves at 10 a uh 10 a.m I don't even
have morals 10 a.m I just don't want to
be there 10 a.m I don't even want to be
there I'm gonna go to sleep I remember
we were playing craps and we're like
let's go to the strip club in barcos oh
sexually harassed everybody because I
bought so many lap dances for everybody
Anthony Lee want to buy me so many lap
dances and I was like no Anthony I will
not do that I need you to stop saying my
full name when you're accusing I like
saying Anthony Lee I can't say Anthony
Lee Anthony Lee Anthony and then the
last thing is for all the fans that are
saying oh lizzo would never do that it's
like how the [__] would you know you
don't know celebrities like you don't
know any of these but she wouldn't
though but she wouldn't
but I think what she did was totally
honestly I think what she did was
totally in line with what most artists
do I think it's more likely and you're
also assuming that you're also probably
assuming that you're camp like that's
your Camp you've probably built some
sort of Rapport yeah you know what I
mean and then it's like imagine if in
this room for whatever reason I bounced
from the crew and then I was like dude
these guys are saying these words and it
was making me uncomfortable you know
what I mean it's like but it's like yo
that was a rapport and I think that's
more likely of a situation than her
actually Force feeding bananas out of
vagina and that's to me it's it's a
great example of the of the thing where
if you want to have honestly if you want
to have a woke environment you will
never be able to keep up with the
standard it will get stricter and
stricter and you will always be a slave
to the next parameter so it's like as
inclusive as she [__] was she still
couldn't keep up nope you know what I
mean do you remember the Madonna tour in
like the 90s when they did it it's like
truth or dare I think is what it's
called right they did the documentary
and she's like in there like flirting
with her dancers sexually harassing
their dancers like grabbing her dancers
dicks and [__] this is just how dancing
this is how dancers get treated they're
just pieces of meat for us to touch all
the time
[Music]